we have a new generation of young people
they're coming into the workforce
they're coming into the marketplace and
in their culture is the new culture of
work at their fingertips they have
better tools than exist in some of our
most sophisticated corporations and if
there's a real danger that companies
will come out of this recession
demographically sort of looking like
Italy now don't be confused you know I
love Italy food people wine culture and
so on but the demographics of Italy it's
a country with a lot of old people not a
lot of young people Japan's even worse
actually they have old people and
restrictive immigration policy so you
don't want to emerge from the recession
without with a company of old people
because you're in deep trouble you'll be
unable to make the big changes to your
business model and strategy enabled by
the internet that young people are
energizing within our corporations
young people are in the workforce the
bright-eyed bushy-tailed what do we do
we stick them in a cubicle supervise
them treat them like Dilbert and rather
than embracing their tools like social
networks and blogs and wiki's and jams
and so on we ban them we do the opposite
of what we should do and banning
Facebook is a totally dysfunctional
thing to do now if employees are wasting
their time on Facebook that's an
opportunity to talk about about real
issues one youngster for my book grown
up digital i asked i asked him 27 years
old works for US federal agency what was
the effect of banning facebook and he
said it was the single most demoralizing
thing the management has ever done it
said we don't understand your tools we
don't understand you we don't get
collaboration and we don't trust you so
take a page from bestbuy the CEO there
brad anderson says my job is not just to
make decisions it's to create the
conditions whereby people can
self-organize to create value and I says
the most important people in this
company or the Blueshirts the young
people work in the stores tens of
thousands of them their closest to our
customer most like our customer and in
their culture is the 21st century dust
by and between them and me are layers
and layers of management trying to
prevent them from changing the company
so he says my job is to give them a
license to self-organize so to your
point they self-organized it's 25,000 of
them created social network called blue
shirt nation they feel engaged they
collaborate they talk about things they
share problems but rather than a sort of
command and control hierarchy they have
a networked organization where where
where people use these powerful new
tools for collaboration to have a sense
of ownership in the company and that's
even more important in tough times like
this
the financial services industry needs a
lot more than a fresh infusion of
capital them some new regulation it
needs a whole new modus operandi where
integrity is baked into the DNA of the
industry you know principles like
interdependence and emergence and and
transparency and and and and
self-organization I mean these are the
new design principles for our 21st
century institutions so if you look at
the challenges facing any individual
business or government or whatever in
this much broader context you're not
going to just slash and burn as we have
done in traditional recessions you're
going to stand back think strategically
and think about where does our business
need to go to compete and to be
successful in this new environment
it's causing us to think very
differently about everything like
marketing I don't think you should focus
on your customers you should engage them
and co innovate with them you shouldn't
build products or services you should
create customer experiences you
shouldn't try and build your brand as an
image a word in the mind a promise a
badge that's not what the brand is
anymore the brand is becoming a complex
construct where integrity is at the
foundation of it in a relationship is
more important than an image you know
the four PS of marketing product place
price and promotion these are all
completely inadequate to understand how
to compete in this new environment
I have a modest proposal that we need to
rethink risk management and we need to
apply the principles of wiki nomics mind
my book to risk number one is we should
be sharing intellectual property risk
models algorithms and data should be
placed in the Commons we should have a
human genome of risks management or
Linux of risk management well we would
never do that our risk models are a
source of proprietary competitive
advantage people say to me well how low
did anyone notice they not only didn't
confer competitive advantage
collectively they led to the downfall of
the entire industry created a massive
global crisis so the idea is that you
share some of your intellectual property
and a rising tide lifts all boats and
then you compete on a higher level
sharing we need to have transparency
based in to risk management we need to
have peering the financial services
industry and its leader should get
together and act as peers rather than
being the recipients or victims of
government legislation they had to grab
the bull by the horns reinvent their
industry around these principles
transform risk management and do the
right thing present a new modus operandi
a new operating model for risk and for
financial services